[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is and I will be your
host today so without further Ado let's
dive into today's episode and embark on
a great journey to together get ready to
be engaged entertained and inspired
today's topic will be about sports when
we will talk more about the sport of
volleyball its benefits how it is the
sport of the volleyball in our society
it is is it a lik sport or no and so on
so for today to discuss all of these
things I have chosen to speak from my
perspective regarding that I am a coach
and professional player and it is my
pleasure that I'm here to answer
questions for volleyball so to begin
with I will introduce myself and I will
tell you for how long I have been
playing volleyball and for how long I am
dealing as volleyball coach in
volleyball club Pristina
Elite I am Le and this is my second year
of being a volleyball coach and I hope I
will continue still being a volleyball
coach and and I'm a volleyball player
since 2016 maybe as a professional
volleyball
player
uh is also my second year and I think I
will continue to be like that for a
while and here is my first question for
me but don't forget in the end we will
have section only for q&as there are
from people who love volleyball and the
question says tell us more about the
volleyball as a sport
and uh it's good things and how does it
affect two volleyball
player okay volleyball is a group sport
as we know and this is one of the
reasons that makes volleyball too good
for its players because volleyball
unites uh youths and uh that are playing
it in fact uh makes them more uh
communicative and without dots willable
affs in a positive ways to its players
such such as reflexes makes them faster
and more open-minded in the term of
putting them to think more about one
thing and so many other
benefits now question is about to
explain the volleyball match and the
main purpose of
match volleyball is a sport which is
played by two teams by six players in
both teams and separated by a net and
there are five sets in game and the
match is played with the rule best of
three which means whoever wins three
sets will win all
game the main purpose of game is that
with three allow touches to make the
ball touch in touch in the field of
opponent and after the ball touches the
ground the point will be for them who
did that action and it and it is a very
enjoying thing because when I play and
uh we score a go a good point with a
long rally it is really something
different starting from reception of
service uh setting the ball and spiking
it uh it is really something
enjoyable are there too many requests
for from new
players uh to join in your team says
next question in fact yes there are too
many uh requests to to join our club uh
and as a result of that we have more
than two 200 players and the number is
increasing day after
day and to conclude with questions that
are made by
staff uh can you tell us the feelings of
being a coach in the last is the last
question actually being a coach is a
very good feeling because you are
training someone who loves something
that you know better than him or her and
you you try to give your best to improve
his or her skills and without doubt it's
an it it is an Indescribable
feeling and now we have we will continue
with Q&A session we will answer some
question we have gotten from
volleyball for volleyball and the
question the first question is is it
hard to be a good volleyball
player actually yes it is hard because
vol requests to uh to train every day to
have a good stamina to have a great
health and some other things in general
but if we analyze the techniques and
things we will have a complicated thing
in front of us but after all of that you
will have an in Indescribable
feeling and now question number two how
often often do rotations happen during a
game nice question
actually uh rotation is a rule that
depends in the way of game uh what do I
mean by that I mean that rotation has a
specific rule is uh when it happens and
how uh but there may
happen that in a set uh is only one
rotation but it means that set is 1 by
25 Z but in general there are many times
that rotation
happens and now let's see third
question uh how do rules differ in Beach
volley ball compared to Indo volleyball
and how does it affect your approach to
the
game uh interesting question in fact
rules of of beach volleyball and indoor
volleyball are known or known as classic
volleyball are almost
different all rules that are same of
these two volleyball games are three
touches a load and if ball strikes or
touches a line of
field is point from all rules that are
in volleyball game only these two rules
are same for these types of volleyball
game but if we compare a classic
volleyball match with a beach volleyball
match we can not notice very easily that
in classic laball uh are too many rules
and it is strier stricter game like for
example in beach volleyball are only two
players and cannot be substituent by
anyone whereas in classic volleyball
roster of the match usually has 14
players and there there can be
substitutions uh another example of
rules is catching the ball if you are
playing classically ball and you are
catching the ball I mean in terms of
staying in your palms for half for maybe
half of a second the point will be for
your opponent whereas in beach
volleyball if you don't catch the ball
the point will be at will be for your
opponent and that is all for
today uh I hope that you enjoyed my
content I hope too much that you learned
at least something
new thank you thank you so much for
joining us on this episode of high
school memories it has been an
incredible journey and you are so glad
you came along for the ride and until
next time take
[Music]
care
oh